that's on for you now chairman
thank you very much indeed
good morning everyone uh welcome
members to this meeting of the flood
advisory group
um also a warm welcome to
members of the uh
our community our public
who may be looking at this on our
youtube channel live
and
as i look down the list
i
look at the membership and at the moment
i don't know whether we've received any
apologies from
for absence have we received any
in that case
i look down at the membership
uh unless i'm mistaken i can't see uh
councillor mrs judy gooding
councillor norman
council of wilson
counselor
this is western
so i can't see them on screen and at the
moment we've not received apologies am i
correct
okay
have we got any visiting members
no chairman
thank you very much indeed
as i say uh a warm welcome uh for
everyone this morning um
welcome also to uh
our office of team uh looking around uh
jeff stacy will be the main officer
player this morning taking us through
the uh various reports uh but also
welcome to matt harwood white
uh of course welcome to uh
you veronica from democratic services
you'll be looking after the
minutes and the reporting on that
um i can see
uh dave chapman
who
is from county council
and
i'm not sure of your official title
roger but i believe it's big projects in
on etsy county council is that correct
so yeah um an fcrm advisor but yes i do
work on projects in this area that's
correct
um and it looks to me as if
chapman is is
a big bun um
i'll maybe get a bit confused roger your
environment agency aren't you sorry yeah
yeah that's right yeah right environment
agency
um and
david chapman essex county council your
big projects
i am indeed so yeah i managed their
flood mitigation capital program yes
thank you um welcome uh mark lloyd
is he on the call yet
he's from anglia water
not
here as far as i can see
um
the other
absence is from essex county council
highways department and bearing in mind
that the number of issues that we talk
about impact on our highways i'm a
little bit disappointed that we don't
get a representative from highways and
to that end i would like an action um
raised with uh officially preparing a
lecture two highways um
at officer level but i would like a copy
of it because i would like to raise it
with
our county councillors who i'm sure uh
support me in our desire that we have
someone from highways here
and um
also i will be writing to the portfolio
holder um councillor lee scott to
make that point uh councillor sure you
put up your hand
i've just sent an an email to lee
as you've been speaking regarding we
haven't got a highways member okay thank
you um and davey chapman you wish to
come in
yeah could i just ask um who who we've
been because normally we used to get um
roger richard baronoski i don't know
whether or not the invite has been
extended to somebody else or or whether
or not there's um just who you've been
contacting to see whether or not i can
um point you in the right direction if
not or maybe see if i can do anything
internally to to get them to come along
now that's really kind of you thank you
thank you david i gather it's a policy
now that um
they do not support uh these meetings
but bearing in mind that we are only one
of two
i think district or borough councils
across uh um essex that have a flood
forum meeting uh it's just a little bit
disappointing that uh we don't get
supported but uh um there we are
councillor cheryl rowe
thank you chairman um it's a shame
really because richard baroness is
[Music]
unfortunately councillor we're losing
you on your your current link
now
you're dipping in and out unfortunately
but uh certainly if i understand the
subject
um mr baronovsky was extremely
supportive but uh and it's in no way
criticism of him um i would make that
quite clear
uh jeff stacy you wish to come in uh
yes it's just to say that uh
richard has uh continued to support us
um it's not able to to join us for the
meeting
um and he has sent me quite a lot of
information which i will feed it at the
appropriate points
when we go through the agenda
okay lovely thank you very much indeed
um
and um
i would just make a general point that
looking at the agenda
and looking at the questions and looking
at the um
response in various areas this whole
business of the flood forum
is starting to turn into a monster i
think members will probably agree with
me that it's turning into being very
broad um and what i will be asking
through the correct governance channels
to do is to have a
through our own review and scrutiny
process actually have a little uh review
uh of um
the terms of reference of the flood
forum
because we start to pick up all sorts of
strategic matters
in relation to
flooding across the district and
opportunity for comments on planning
rather than necessarily focusing on
specific issues which as i said earlier
we are a non-statutory service but we do
like to pull the various agencies
together to come up with solutions uh
council mrs mason
yeah thank you simon
i would
certainly agree that we need to look at
this forum and the meeting and whether
it's meeting its objectives and are
there adequate and appropriate resources
and other resources being used in an
effective way to achieve timely outcomes
so i'm pleased that you're going to put
this to review
but bearing in mind that the workload of
the review committee i wonder if it
could
perhaps be done by another process a
small working group
i'll leave that to you to just determine
um but certainly
the suitability of this forum and its
process needs to be looked at i think
it's a matter of urgency so i'd
certainly welcome your suggestion thank
you
that's kind of accountability mason um
you certainly said that out very very
well indeed so you're supporting me and
i totally support you
so
i think initially it does go through a
review process because that is our
formal governance whether or not it
falls out by having a working group task
and finish or whatever i'm pretty
relaxed on but i'm getting quite
concerned at uh
the very diverse very broad
agenda and to be honest this meeting is
scheduled for a maximum of two hours and
to do the subjects justice we could be
here for six hours doing some of this
stuff so uh um you know i just think we
need to
get better focus on it and review the
effectiveness so thank you
quite right the partnership at the
moment seems confused and there's a loss
of history and and probably a waste of
time and resources so certainly needs to
be improved so thank you for making that
on board lovely thank you um and
councillor joe mcpherson
um thank you chairman
um i can only speak as the vice chairman
of the review committee
but we are a strong committee we've just
gone through a review of ourselves
so that we are more efficient as well
from an external body
and we are quite great in numbers
so i would welcome this coming to the
review committee i'm sure that we can
task members with this because it is a
hugely important issue to our residents
thank you chairman
thank you councillor general person um
right it looks if you know even though
it's not on the agenda i've got
agreement to something already
because the intention here by everyone
present is to be effective in terms of
outcomes and i think in that respect
through no one's fault we could start to
lose our way
we're trying to tackle issues that are
frankly uh far bigger than us and of
course i do emphasize the fact it's a
non-statutory service that we're trying
to quite rightly uh do good for our
district by pulling the agencies
together so uh welcome um environment
agency welcome essex county council um i
don't know whether anglia will have
joined us yet haven't seen anyone
there join us yet but we move on with
the meeting so uh um i've taken
apologies for absence
there are none but there's a number of
members missing um but if we move on to
item two which is to agree the minutes
of the meeting held on the first of
november um i've got a couple of hands
councilman mason are you is that a new
hand it is a new hand indeed uh council
woodson um
if you recall
at the last meeting uh councillor
mcpherson commented that one site had
been unresolved for 12 years
in view of this i requested that the
date of origination of each area of
concern was inserted into the reports
so the progress or the lack of progress
could be easily identified
my recollection of this is that it was
agreed
but it does not appear to have been done
um
could you perhaps
amend the minutes so that that is
included
and perhaps uh we can ensure that it is
done because as i recall it was a
consensus and you yourself supported it
certainly uh council mission base and i
one of the things and i think it is a
matter for review to look at is that my
understanding of this forum should be
that things move in they move
through and they move on and off the
agenda um and we seem to spend an awful
lot of time and sadly you've given up
highlight of 12 years uh you know we
need to reach some conclusion and to be
fair if it's a conclusion that it is
outside of our remits and it's something
that rockstar district council can have
no uh jurisdiction over fair enough but
we do need to that's part of my concern
that things are not moving forward in a
timely fashion but
uh certainly we can get that added uh
councilman mason yes well that was
agreed at the last minute so the minutes
need to be altered and and it needs to
be actioned by the officer thank you
thank you very much i'm sure that's been
noted councillor mike stepped up
yes thanks jim uh with regards to item
three on the notes uh i've raised the
issue that we hadn't got declaration of
interest which have been included this
time around but in my declaration at
that time i would also included that i'm
a member of barling magna parish council
which doesn't appear in the notes
thank you councillor steptoe
and that will be corrected um are there
any other points um
that we wish to record um i did point
out that
my name is spelt wrongly in a couple of
places but uh any minor point um
but uh
apart from that do we agree can i just
uh get a signal from everyone please can
you raise your um
your hand if you're
happy for the you agree to the minutes
lovely i think that's an agreement
thank you which takes us nicely onto
declarations of interest now obviously
we cover a broad range of subjects and
um
declarations may come up as we go along
but if i can take any initial
declarations of interest um that people
are aware of uh council mike steptoe
thank you chairman uh as per the the the
last notes uh i'm a member of essex
county council
also a member of the
ethics flood forum and the a member of
the environmental agency group also the
member of barling medler parish council
and if any issues should come up with
regards to the
stream at the bottom of kimberley road
um just to remind members that that
stream ultimately upstream runs through
my garden
council
councillor mrs shaw
thank you chairman um yeah i'm an essex
county councillor and i'm also a couple
of items on here are in my or wow
uh world eruption north of rural
thank you
thank you very much indeed um
councillor
this is cheryl
thank you chairman
member of town council
thank you
councillor dave sperry
member of brady town council chairman
councillor ward
yeah a member of ridertown council
councilman chris stanley
clark vice chairman member of uh council
thank you
thank you at this stage i think that
completes declarations of interest but
please
chip in if along the way you find
yourself talking about something you
feel you ought to
declare an interest on because uh water
flooding crosses uh many frontiers so it
could be that an organization where part
of is mentioned and we ought to
declare an interest at that point thank
you
which takes us on please to item four
and i'm going to hand over to
jeff stacy i guess um
rather than you matt
jeff stacy to take us through the uh
summary of
flooding issues
reported in the trust forum
and i'm just mindful that this summary
covers points that have been covered in
um
yes it would be um it would be helpful
if jeff you would be kind enough to
cross reference
to the minutes your report and any
questions on the subsequent agenda so
that we don't keep going around in
circles and same items if you'd be kind
enough to do that jeff over to you for
writing four
thank you very much
um
yeah just run through these are they as
they are in the um
the summary of flooding issues uh within
the within district and so starting with
ashington and the the lower washington
road
and got an update from
um
the invite
from
ethics county council highways on on
this one
um they said as uh certainly on the the
lower road washington road as they
previously reported um
it's a difficult traffic
to to attend
we do not have any inquiries relating to
flooding reports
we're reluctant to engage works here at
this time due to significant cost and
network dis
disruption um
then they comment on the area from
moons close to high cliff crescent
um
there's no specific comment on on base
lane which is the next one but the one
after that moon's close to high cliff
crescent
and they say we attended the gullies as
part of our cyclical gully attendance
and that was on the 3rd of february 22.
i'll explain it at
this point um because this crops up on a
regular basis
uh when they refer to cyclical
um
response
that's the the sort of routine gully
clearance
um so that's the sort of the gully
suckers that you see that come in and
clean out the drains um it doesn't
include sort of jetting in any other
work
and they also refer at some times to um
an ad hoc response
um they have one crew
who go around doing specified work
um usually that's
you know where they've been called out
because there's a particular frog
problem with a block drain or flooding
or something like that
um
they will undertake jetting and
investigation work
um so there's those two sort of
responses that we that we get from uh
from highways the cyclical the routine
stuff and the ad hoc one which is a more
sort of one-off which
usually involves uh sort of jetting and
clearing out like that
um so the moon's the moon's close one to
high cliff crescent
um tended gullies as part of our
cyclical gully attendance and that was
on the third of february this year
and the gullies south of the crossing
seem to be clear but there are
consistent reports of water backing up
from the anglian water main
angling water have again been asked to
check their main
um
and then there was a comment uh
nothing further on the
uh entry for ashington road nothing to
to sort of add there
i'm gonna stop you there if i may please
jeff uh because councilman mason has
raised your hand
if you could just ask a short point of
clarification
on the moves close to highly present
it sleeps very clearly that the cycle
called gully cleanses new and the main
road network in the later part of
2021 but it wasn't clear whether this
has been done or not has that been
carried out
yes yes they
um they came on the third of february
yes but to that road but i mean
it says the the main road network would
be done has it been done
if you don't know perhaps you could find
out from this one
yes no i'm just looking at what the uh
comments were
last time
um yeah looking through were there in
2020
and
no issues were found jetting report
again suggests downstream capacity
issues under heavy rainfall which is an
anglian water thing
uh then says the cyclical gully cleanses
is due in the latter part of 2021 which
we've done and they
i say the latest visit they've done was
february 22.
so um
so no they they seem to be undertaking
all the things that they said um
but we'll certainly refer that through
to anglian water again
right um
thank you councilman mason um thank you
jeff in in terms of this report um
look it's been circulated with the
agenda um i would just suggest that we
go through by areas and see whether
there's any questions because members
will have read it unless you've got an
interaction otherwise it'll take an
awfully long time to go through line by
line
report so can we just go through by area
and see whether the members have got any
questions based on the comment that's
written there or if you have anything to
add
yes
there was there was a bit too to sort of
add there for for this one there's not
as much for some of the others
uh yep fine so that unless there's any
further questions that that's it for
washington
uh sort of update there
and next area to look at is um
battles bridge
um i've nothing to
to add beyond what's there at the moment
november is indicating they wish to
prepare it by anything
okay um
again i have nothing specific to
to add to what's there
council stanley you're raising ahead
yes thank thank you chairman uh just a
couple of points that i might can i just
uh say that uh the agenda came to me
with the questions from the public but i
never got anything anything else sent to
me uh for one and also uh if that could
be sorted out with veronica that would
be great um and as for battles bridge um
i was
we're constantly worried at roaring
about the
uh locked gates uh whether they are
monitored whether they're kept open or
what such
we are having a meeting with um
roger uh and uh david uh
soon uh this coming month um
and we're hoping to get some sort of uh
collusion as to what is happening about
the lock gates whether they are
monitored or such
and kept open so yeah thank you
okay thank you council stanley uh with
regard to
your access you get electronic access at
the same time as everyone else um and of
course the state's been in the diary for
some time but if you reach a paper
agenda in advance to help you uh that
really needs to be requested in advance
of the meeting so uh
that's the same situation as you guys
will stand here that was great yeah
i'm sorry i didn't bring that up earlier
chairman thank you
no problem at all
so unless anyone's got any further
comments with regard to battles with
your can you move on
i've got something on canodin just one
point it still hasn't been sorted
thank you
sorry we're getting feedback i think we
had this um
i think
uh jeff stacy i think it's actually your
link we had exactly this problem last
time
um
um
yeah i think when you go on mute it
sorts it out but uh
um
well i think we're all struggling a bit
with feedback we might reconsider
i'm still getting it from elsewhere
certainly feedback
let me mute now see whether that makes
any difference
okay um certainly
the feedback is making it quite
difficult and i mean also laurent shaw
is uh she hasn't she hasn't put her mic
to view well i'm actually talking to
councillor lauren shaw actually
so
i'm trying to have dialogue with
councillor sean can you just repeat the
um item you were talking about um on
canodin that's um
oh it's mentioned that the corner of
ryan kellane scottsdale was filled with
rubbish for in
uh the tarmacking i went up there um
two weeks ago and then it went up again
it's still flooding up there uh because
that drain has not been cleared
um and we could have a potential problem
there thank you that's just one comment
on that
thank you councillor lauren shaw um
right unless there's anything else on
canoe if we can move forward please jeff
okay yeah um
hulk well
um
yeah comments from the um
from
highways
um around
the hollyoak lane
uh
they checked on their asset register and
that's shown as uh
sort of private road so not something
where
they can assist
um
and they comment on
uh rectory road they're saying there's
uh no known issues at this time
i can clarify that please mr chairman
okay i'll just wait for jeff to finish
and bring you in council mississippi
okay thank you yeah
you you go go for it i thought you'd
finished um
right the um rectory road
there was
has been a persistent problem for
something like 12 years
from clement by the opposite um by the
clements gate where the old christmas
tree farm entrance used to be
someone and i don't know whom i'm
assuming it was essex county council did
some uh serious work there because they
had traffic lights up and
it was apparently resolved but now the
problem is back
um
we've had various reports in in the past
that it's coming off of the clemence
gates site that it's blocked drains that
it's a collapse drain
but
the i think the residents were overjoyed
when they thought it had been
resolved
but it is now back again so that needs
to go back on the agenda it's it's
roughly off the opposite or around 300
and i don't know the actual number about
15 i guess
so but it's been a perpetual problem and
of course the
water in the road is so
deep that it's quite dangerous to
traffic if it's unaware of it
so perhaps that that's an additional one
that we need to add in
okay
thank you councilman mason um any other
comments on hawkwell
no
all right we move on to hotly
and yep hopefully
the comments from the
uh highways
and
following
our request attended
[Music]
and they found no issues with the you
know issues were reported
um with with what they've
the the sort of checks that they did
there
um
so that's corn hill avenue
and then they mentioned
park gardens we passed on a
report from councillor mrs mason of a
complaint of repeated flooding there
um
but they're not aware of any reported
flooding so we need some sort of further
information on that one
um otherwise i've no update further
updates to to what's in the report
okay uh just before i bring up the uh
bring in the two people um the corn hill
avenue is a classic example where it
appeared last time we talked about it
it's in the minutes it's now appearing
on the report
um and i think it appears as one of the
questions
um and that is a fairly localized issue
because i'm aware of that and this this
is exactly the sort of thing that should
be being dealt with and we get a
resolution and it moves off um to keep
talking about the same thing is he's
getting a little tiresome um
i'll be honest with you um and this is
precisely why i think this this whole
meeting is getting bogged down with
things that we go around around in
circles and i'll leave councilman mason
to clarify her point on park gardens um
but again it looks to me as if it's a
sort of localized issue which just
needed sorting out let's bring in
council award first of all and then i'll
go to it
yeah thank you very much um yeah this is
on the last item on part 4.4 which is
plumber avenue um
westminster drive and plumber avenue i
think they're separated by a mile
so i don't know why they've been put in
as if they're in close proximity to each
other but i'm more interested in the
plumber avenue which is also
come up in questions
in regards and it was in the minutes as
well as to 126
plumbro avenue which has had masses of
flooding from an underground stream
subject to planning
uh being approved on an application
there
this has not been resolved in any way
and there are lots of residents whose
gardens and sometimes their basements
and areas are being flooded by this
stream which unfortunately was not taken
into consideration when planning was
approved even though we're not not
necessarily talking to planning but it
was refused on three
previous occasions so i do have a big
concern there um i think action does
need to be taken and i do not
necessarily think it's the essex
flood
group that need to do this i think this
needs to be something involved from rdc
as they are the planning authority which
agreed for this application to go
through
okay um thank you council award
uh council mr mason
thank you councilwood uh park gardens i
can say that i've had no further contact
for the residents and i would suggest
that's closed if they're not giving
information i don't see any pointless
following it on
um the other issue that i have here uh
pop gardeners by the way is hulkpo not
hopefully but uh
we'll we'll forgive you on that one
um
westminster drive i just want to
briefly i think this um situation here
summarizes the difficulties that
council wouldn't and i
have um alluded to earlier
very briefly
in august 2013 six properties were
damaged in the region of about 70 000
each i think um
severely in that area
the the ditches were cleared by the
authorities
and in the last year or so the ditches
have now have debris which has naturally
occurred
and they are concerned
in november
i had an email saying we've got no
knowledge of flooding in the area but
we're continuing to investigate
um
and with
another email ask the residents to
contact the essex flood team well it
seems that we're going around in circles
and is that the right advice for our
residents when we're already aware of it
and it's being dealt with by the flood
forum
and the residents simply want to know
who owns the land and who's responsible
for it and after eight years i would
have hoped that that information
would be available
and so far it's not
so we we're
we've had an issue
we've obsessively resolved it we've got
the potentiality of a repeat issue eight
years later and yet no one seems to have
any knowledge or information that can
prevent that
and
i think that's concerning and that's why
i just strongly support councillor
woodson's um
putting this to the review committee
because either we have got inadequate
resources or we're not using them
properly
and this really needs to be looked at
but westminster drives is still
outstanding and has moved further not at
all
so further investigation yes but it
should be done
you know not
it shouldn't take us a year or two to do
this
okay thank you
thank you very much and and certainly i
agree with you uh
our gardens is in awkward uh but the
good news is it is one item that's going
to drop off so
and i also support you and your latter
point as an example to my earlier
statement okay
moving on then to holbridge
jeff
sorry come off mute that that'll help
um okay in addition to what's down there
for
the whole bridge
um
on watery lane uh highway say
preventative cleanse
and any other maintenance issues is
planned
with a road closure
this has been delayed this year as we
cannot get the relevant closure permit
due to a multitude of utility works
on the diversion route
so that's their
comment there
no no further comments on any of the uh
the other areas certainly don't care
about some caravan park is a subject
it's an item of its own on item five so
we'll we'll defer that one to lighting
five um but
any other member questions in relation
to old bridge please
no
okay
we move on to
rayleigh uh please jeffy
yeah rayleigh the um
only additional information is
there's a lot where they're saying it's
um as per the the sort of previous
minute
um
the wins away
they're saying was attended by our
cyclical gully crew
in november last year gullies were
cleaned and no defects were reported at
that time
and so that's the only additional piece
of information
on
what's down there currently
thank you very much i have um councillor
ward wishing to come in
thank you chairman uh just wanting an
update on grove road
um with regard to the pumping which was
promised by anglian water
various residents are still very
concerned that nothing has been done
and
just wondered
when are we going to have a site meeting
i haven't had one it says aw agreed to a
site meeting with a member still waiting
okay
point by council award and unfortunately
anglia walter don't seem to be with us
this morning so uh if that could be
taken away as an action unless you
haven't answered yet
uh
no i have
not been in contact with anglian water
recently
okay um
thank you for that uh council award
for
your link is absolutely terrible uh
councillor rogue um
we're only getting every other word i'm
afraid
okay well just to say that wins away is
clear they have done they've done the
drains again since the flooding
in january
um
thank you for that on the point of
drain clearance
um i do want to give credit to county
council um for what now seems to be the
real storation of routine maintenance
they do seem to be more regularly going
round to drains it really frustrates me
that we have a drainage infrastructure
and the first point of flooding issues
is to make sure that the infrastructure
that is already in place is maintained
and it does appear from observation that
there is a much better um
regime and timetable of routine
maintenance so certainly county
councillors on this call and your
colleagues
take that back as a uh as a positive
point but that is so so important that
um that routine maintenance is carried
on as well as time to time specific
it's not good enough to look down drains
parts of the highways infrastructure and
see them absolutely full of rubbish and
growing grass out of them rather than
draining water it can't be a surprise
when it rains they then don't do their
job um
council board do you want to come back
uh yes please this is just moving down
the list
this was on eastwood rise this has been
an ongoing problem since 2008
when the road was done uh mr phillip
lord of essex county council
promised that the work would be done and
those people who contributed towards
this road were promised it would be
adoptable and a letter
affirming that was sent to all residents
that letter still remains with the legal
department at essex
please try and find out why they keep on
refuting
this letter
okay that's an action point that's going
to be taken away thank you very much
right moving on from brady we come to
rockford uh jeff
yeah no additional comments to add to
what's there
inquiries
our council stepped up
yes thank you jim
on the
if anybody has driven along it you'll
know what i mean but i refer to the
ditch that's now been dug out towards
the canal
um
council recently have carried out a
survey of the drainage system there
because the ditch that was required to
be dug out by essex county council of
the land owner
has done has got no outlet into the
stream
the water just sits there
i haven't as of yet received
any
report on what that server has
found
so until that survey comes back i can't
see what action can now be taken we need
to
understand what's going on there
okay that will be taken away as a action
to
investigate
thank you
with regards to the whole road
development
uh i have been in discussions with uh
beltway the developers and i will
compliment that they have been very very
helpful um along with the planning
department we've been talking to them
there's been a number of issues raised
by those residents that live actually
you know grow that back on to the
development
there is a a couple of concerns that
we're still working on but the beltways
are being very very responsive on it
but there is an issue
where their subsystem or their
alleviation system runs out
into
the stitch that runs alongside um
fine well lane
the culvert then goes under ironwheel
lane
and goes into and some people call it
the uh hawkwood brook some people call
it the roach
um where it runs in and there is a
slush gate
and the flat from the skate is missing
at this stage i've been unable to
identify who is responsible for that
sluice bait
the issue is that when the uh referred
to as the roach
um is at high levels the water can back
feed
up underneath the culvert straight into
uh underhall and ironwell
and then potentially
block out any of the outlet from the sub
system
because the sub system in
hall road uh the elizabeth gardens give
its correct name
does not flow directly
into the roach the potential is there
that it will run into the ditch and then
the ditch will fill up
and run down hall road towards rockford
flooding the properties in a road so
there is still a lot of work working
there behind the scenes
with belleway on that particular issue
thank you councillor steptoe and that
that really is a very important point
that if these valves go missing
and they're very crude sort of valves
they can then at high tide do quite the
reverse and cause a problem with uh the
back filling and uh that's
you know that's uh something we've got
to um highlight so again an action will
be taken away to work with you on that
councillor
and uh at the age i could just correct
you there that it's not tidal at that
point it's a case of whether the flow of
the roach is exceptionally high because
it's dealing with other right
and run over the level of the uh the
switzerland okay okay quite happy with
that but the point is that if the water
the wrong side of the valve is higher
for other reasons so the valve's not
there you can get back pulling and
so
yeah we need to make sure that that is
you know the valve is doing what it's
intended to do
um because the consequence of it not
doing what it's intended to do creates a
worse problem um so
we'll get on to that uh council award
yeah just to declare an interest uh in
regards to as a pecuniary interest in
rochford hundred golf club it was on the
bottom just come up um
i just wanted to know uh what is
happening going onwards from this place
yes certainly if you'd like me to
comment on it mr chairman um
working with the the um
trying to understand the
the statistically
the whole of this uh
this area
um so coming down from in fact from um
all the way from hotly woods right down
to this area
and then through the golf course and
through
to uh to to rochford and the horse and
groom and all that sort of area
i've been trying to sort of get a wider
understanding of how this all sort of
reacts together and that's in the
separate report that uh
we're covering under um
uh
sort of item six
um so perhaps if i i can sort of comment
a little more at that stage okay
thank you
right nothing else on rockford
yes there's no further
additional comments to to what's in the
uh the report at the moment
from uh highways
thank you
okay then councillor this is joe
mcpherson
john mutes joe
crumps i haven't done that for ages
um
first of all uh the comments in there
aren't actually that reflective of the
minutes from the last meeting
um i had
requested as mark lloyd was here from
anglia water
that they would have a look at the
sewage system there and the pipe system
which he kindly agreed to do
they did actually come out in the 10th
of february
mark kindly gave me a full report after
the inspection
the sewage was cleared
it was then
fully inspected to make sure that there
was no overgrowth or collapsed pipes or
anything like that and it was flowing
clear to the off
which is the outfall
the outfall
pipe comes into the dry ditch at the
rear
of the recreation ground
now there is mention there that um uh
rdc acid management investigating works
to improve capacity of the ditches
february 22. um it was actually on the
7th of march that i went out myself with
the asset manager
now our part of the ditch
is clear
and has capacity
however
we don't do not have riparian rights on
the whole of the ditch
some of the riparian rights obviously
belong to the farmer but also there is
sanctuary land and also land at the rear
of the football club
so we need to ascend whose
responsibility is to clear that
and until that is cleared
we are still going to have this ongoing
situation where my residents cannot
actually physically get off their drive
because they'd be walking through a few
feet of water
so if that can be taken back and sorted
please jeff
um
i i am surprised sometimes that we're
not a little bit stronger with some of
this riparian rights um enforcement
and uh make sure that that is done
please um
i have to give full credit to mark lloyd
in his defense to my knowledge this is
the first meeting of the flood forum
that he has not been here representing
anglian walton water and what he has
offered to do
he is always fulfilled so perhaps if we
just note that and perhaps other
partners could um you know follow his
lead
so to speak
um
uh shoulder stick i will let my uh the
ward counsellor my colleague councillor
steptoe speak on that one um kimberly
wrote um this this issue is actually
borders both of our wards
um
again
that's not quite correct what is there
the repairs of the bank have been
carried out
they've been carried out
by the riparian
land owners so the residents
that are there
now although that has been done
i wish for this one and i presume uh
councillor steptoe will support it stays
on
the agenda because we also have to do uh
the accompanying problem with the pump
system there so we need to keep our eye
on this and see
if the watercourse is now
flowing
well enough
to stop any further flooding
um again we have the point of slain
wakerim road
um
again it says there quite clearly it's
noted that the ditches need further
maintenance
what have we done about this
otherwise the issue is not going to go
and when we're looking at further or
future development i think when all
these come up we can quite clearly see
that certain areas are unsustainable for
this
i'll hand over to my colleague now mike
so just just before we bring mike in
look i i i totally support your comment
about um
our enforcement towards riparian
landowners um
it's a really important point this is
because it is part of the drainage
infrastructure
um
over many many years we've seen
farmers in particular um in the style of
farming close the old-fashioned ditch
network um
where the pipes have been put under
under there who knows but um if the
fundamental infrastructure which drains
strange management and ditches are not
cleared
then that causes a problem so i can't
stress more strongly my agreement with
your point on getting letters out
in a timely fashion
uh under the riparian whites people seem
to think ditches
particularly when they're dry are just
good areas for them to dump their garden
refuse or whatever
especially if you aren't aware of one
ditch where that happens particularly
and i also am full of your praise for
anglian water as indeed other agencies
um but uh bulk is particularly active on
taking on these things so why he's not
here today i'm sure there's a good
reason but uh it's absolutely no
criticism of angry water um because we
value the importance of their attendance
to to deal with these things so thank
you very much indeed
yeah just one more point please chairman
um ditches are hugely important to our
drainage system but when you've also got
historic villages such as great wakering
and then we're having bolt-on
developments which have their own sewage
system
it does not work
when the old system is at full capacity
already because it will just push onto
there as well and create even greater
problems than we've already um dealing
with
thank you you will be very well aware
council person my views about
infrastructure and infrastructure
happens in all sorts of ways and uh
you've heard me say many times it is no
good bolting a uh
a new sewage system onto old
infrastructure piping so uh
i agree with that point too council
stepped up i think you possibly want to
come in for some reason i'll come in on
all of those items but first of all i'd
just like to put a question to uh dave
chapman
uh if you could uh
confirm that my thoughts are correct
um the
action of enforcement for riparian
landowners with as far as ditches are
concerned i believe rests with county
rather than district
and in which case if i'm correct i think
that that is quite a major resource
problem within county
so yes just to come back on council step
towards question the um
watercourse enforcement
um where
um
there is either um
misuse of a watercourse or something
that's been done consented there is an
enforcement procedure that exes county
council can take out
unfortunately that does not extend to um
capacity increases
capacity increase is not an enforceable
option but certainly
uh unkept maintenance and um
unconsensual work is yes
so
there is still a if i if i'm correct uh
my understanding is that there is one
person within county division that deals
with this for the whole county
there is yes it's uh it's we have one
watercourse engineer that deals with
county-wide issues yes there is also um
an enforcement uh officer that deals
with highways enforcement related issues
um so there's a separate team that deals
with those we are looking at more of the
residential issues where houses and
properties and businesses are affected
um highways have their own enforcement
department but again i think that's
limited to one person so yeah there is
resourcing issues with that
thank you thank you that just clarifies
my thoughts on that particular point so
that's something that as county members
we need to progress with the portfolio
um with regards to
the items uh under the wakering uh the
first item there that uh councilman
fearson uh
mentioned there um i can't remember the
exact number of the house there but
that's towards the higher end of the
numbers of the high street i think
that's referring to there is a another
uh issue
um on the lower numbers that i from
memory i believe is number 75 which has
a similar issue which has still not been
addressed and my concern is it's got
sort of muddled up with this item so i'd
like perhaps to
go back and re revisit that um second
one
um
with regards to the barley roll near the
the old solder stick uh that is very
much down to the riparian land owners
it's quite complicated down there
because where the ditches were running
and now run and various things
but that is down to the land owners so
that is something that does need to
perhaps have some enforcement
one of those ditches now
again dave david will advise me here um
will runs along the edge of the road
so is that uh under road enforcement or
is it under the riparian um
enforcement
so again
casa stepped over you're correcting is
that that is a little bit that can be um
another area of uncertainty but the
general rule of thumb
is that um the highway responsibility
finishes where a ditch starts so the
ditch repairing ownership will belong
solely to the landowner behind that
unless there is a reason for that to
have been changed so it may well be for
example that the highways have safety
issues or they've decided to extend the
road and pipe the section of ditch work
then they will then become owners for
that area but generally the rule of farm
unless stated otherwise that will be a
riparian ownership for the landowner at
the rear of the ditch and not highways
so it will be the enforcement officer
that we were talking about earlier it is
yes yeah
okay with with regards to the kimberley
road um issue that um casper mcfish
mentioned there again i'll just remind
members that waterfalls does run up into
through my garden and does take all of
the water runoff from the new two new
developments
um both star lane and um
there is actually two issues there and
again i perhaps like to see them
separated out slightly
is one is with regards to the pumping
station which is the responsibility
of uh anchor water as you can imagine
the two issues get muddled up because
when the ditch does flood it then floods
into the sewage system
so that's the reason that it's all in
one but i think we need to keep those
two slightly separated
otherwise we could find it drops off the
system uh and only half of it's actually
been dealt with uh i hope councilman
mcpherson will agree on that particular
point
other than that chairman i think i'll
leave you with that lovely thank you uh
councillor german person you want to
come back
thank you chairman um once i can
appreciate this it's county council may
have limited capacity and the resource
of only one enforcement officer
we now have technology
we have um things such as what three
words which will pinpoint the exact
position
we have the ability to send photographs
electronically
um i'm never so sorry um it may only be
one person but perhaps if essex county
council could review their reporting
structure and how we can report these
issues to them that may actually assist
the officer in future enforcement thank
you
yup thank you um but just to come back
on that uh chairman i would totally
agree with that
yeah
and
yeah i
can i just uh chairman is it right if i
just respond to councilman if that's all
right yeah sure
uh yes um there is a there's a central
email address if that if that i can if
you want me to share that i can share
that any information photographs mapping
information all of that stuff can be
sent over via email we will then record
that on our system and we will action
accordingly it the one officer means
doesn't mean that we won't get around to
doing it just may mean that we may take
a little bit longer
get getting out to those but if you can
highlight anything on the emails such as
properties that are affected or
if there's any known flood history all
of that goes to help us to prioritize
these investigations and and taking them
forward for whatever action is suitable
to resolving those but that information
i'll put the floods email address in the
chat as well so that people that don't
have that can
can access that and email us over and
put that for the attention of our
workhorse engineer yeah
thank you it might be an option as well
to make it available to the public who
might like to report issues direct
okay thanks that can also be done online
so
all of that information and also the way
in which you can contact us is all the
information that can be found on our
flooding web page i will also put the
flooding web page address in the chat as
well for people share
thank you
thanks for that good point but i mean we
move on to or move into that um
sensitive area about resourcing but to
be honest if there's a job to be done
there has to be a proportionate amount
of resource to uh to deal with it um and
um
we could say that in all sorts of
council services it is a juggling act
and there has to be
uh proportionality in this but uh um you
know we really can't stand by and watch
people people's premises at the risk of
flooding and just turn around and say
well there's a lack of resource in a
particular area to deal with it we have
to get some sort of proportionate
balance on on the whole thing um but
using technology of course um the way we
did things 20 30 years ago
certainly needs to be being reviewed to
a good point councillor chris stanley
thank you chairman um it was just a uh
just to pick up on a couple of points
there about highways and uh county
council and and
the way they work together that doesn't
seem that at this
as you very well know roriff is and i
don't know if that's on the agenda at
all um rorith um the the pumping out of
the fair glen into a reservoir which is
not big enough now to take that volume
of water it overflows it goes into rory
through the
uh
through the channels um where
when he is in flood and those pumps are
switched on that also floods roaring um
so there is items there that need to be
clarified with uh ish's county council
yourself david and and the highways
again
in part where the highway as they put
the bypass uh they cut off the channel
which actually takes water underneath
that bypass they literally cut it off
and the water doesn't go anywhere
so that sort of thing is needs to be
with with highways as well thank you
i agree with you council standing this
second time you've referred to the
agenda
and you said i think your statement was
you're not sure whether it's on the
agenda or not
um i referred earlier to the agenda pack
have you got a copy of the agenda or not
okay all right uh there's a bit of a
shame
and certainly i would suggest for future
meetings you definitely need a copy of
the agenda in front of you uh either
electronic or paper so uh but i i can
tell you that it's not on today's agenda
as a specific item other than through
the um other other than through the um
individual geographical areas that we've
yeah the idea of this is to cover all
geographical areas but uh um that point
is made councillor steptoe
yes chairman just a thought here um as a
lot of these issues coming up are under
the heading of essie's county council uh
it would make sense to me that in future
meetings although they might not be
members of the forum is that all essex
county councillors should be invited to
this meeting uh because later on in the
meeting there are items that are coming
up that i wasn't aware of because
they've not been reported to me
but it would make sense for essence
county councillors to be part of this
meeting so there's a number of items
that they can take pick up and deal with
off offline rather than the platform
yeah thank thank you councillors
very good point there and
i certainly took a view when i started
becoming chair of this meeting that
geographically we want to make sure that
all areas are covered um member-wise we
need to make sure that all areas are
covered and certainly member
responsibility-wise we need to make sure
all areas are covered
otherwise we just constantly spend their
life referring to other agencies and
other authorities and that i think comes
back to my earlier point strongly
supported by council mrs christie mason
that we just need to look at all of this
stuff so that we make this meeting as
productive and as useful as possible
take fully take your point on board i
agree with you right um so that's
covered the geographical uh side of the
um
district if we can move on to the
specifics
again item five the report has been um
presented to us uh with the detail um
and um
jeff stacey if you want to take us to
through any items on item 5.
yes really the doom caravan park because
of the
potential risks to
you know sort of quite a large number of
the
residential caravans in that area
um
we
work with partners on that one to
to sort of look at what was the risk
and what were the issues who were where
were the responsibilities
um that's now all all sort of put into
to that report to to sort of clarify
um
when in fact we've found that the the
risk is is a lot less than suspected
um but we have also sort of clarified
the responsibilities and so on
pass that report on to all the
interested parties
um
really as far as the flood forum's
concern we're not anticipating
undertaking any further work in in that
sort of area
having passed all the necessary
information on to the
to the to the parties that are
responsible
um
so unless there's any
comments to the to the contrary to
to a great extent i think we should be
able to draw a line under that one
uh jeff all i would like to do because
i've been personally involved i've been
out on several site visits there i would
like to thank you for the work you've
done and the way you put report together
um but i don't think we just let it go
because we need to hold the accountable
bodies
accountable and responsible for
solutions because there seems to be some
infrastructure failings there
i know your comment about
risk assessment
but the simple fact is the
infrastructure isn't working there's
several um
dated landowners there um but i don't
want a situation where
um a
combination of circumstances that only
ever occur once in a hundred years to
happen um you know more frequently uh
and then find that we call down it needs
to be addressed the various accountable
bodies need to deal with it and our role
may be nothing more than monitoring um
and reporting back so i wouldn't like us
to
just dismiss it as job done because
we've done a very excellent report a lot
of hard work on your part um but i don't
think we can just back away from it we
need to hold this is part of the
responsibility of this web forum to make
sure the jobs we identify being done are
done to resolve issues um so
thank you for that um
i thought i saw council steppo's hand
yeah i completely echo what you just
said around that area we do need to keep
an update we can't just say okay we've
done it and just pass it on we need to
make sure that we monitor what is
actually being done because if we don't
we are failing our residents
lovely thank you
david i don't know whether you want to
come in there because i would have
thought that it starts to uh border on a
big project issue
yeah sure um
so the area in and around hotly is
something that we've done work on
previously um as part of the capital
flood program but also i'm pleased to
um say that we've got a bigger
feasibility study that will be carried
out at the start during the next
financial year to cover many of these
operations
or look at these options again the
information that's provided in report
will be very helpful and used as some
history so that we can build up our
knowledge of what goes on in that area
and that's very very helpful
but the feasibility study that we look
to to carry out at some point during the
next financial year will cover a lot of
those options and then i can then bring
those options back to this group to show
where we've decided to take it whether
or not there are benefits that we can
provide by doing certain schemes
obviously there's a criteria that we
look at when we deliver schemes
primarily it's around the amount of um
residential properties that will benefit
from an option
but also critical infrastructure
previous flood history and also now in
equal measures a lot of the
environmental benefits that we can look
to try and achieve from our capital
schemes will be taken into account so
there's no guarantee that there will be
something to take forward but this will
feed into that feasibility study process
so that we've got all that area covered
and hopefully at the end of that process
we'll have a scheme or a number of
different different options that we can
look to take forward and i'll i'll keep
the board updated on that
okay uh thank you david on that um but
the simple fact there is the
old infrastructure um or the
infrastructure is just plain broken i've
seen it for myself and um if it was good
enough to put it in there in the past it
would seem to me that it should either
be maintained or replaced or you know
it's whether or not it's viewed as a
new project or whether or not it's
ongoing maintenance of the existing
project um but i would prefer it not to
get bound up in
priority you know if you're good enough
to put it there in the first place one
assumes that
the reasons for it being there um
the flood alleviation continues so uh
but thank you very much indeed but we
should carry on monitoring it unless
there's any other comments in relation
to item 5 we'll move on
no can't see anyone indicating um item 6
yes this report was
trying to understand um a number of
reports that we'd received to the
the flood forum
um
running really from um
bellshamps
through hawkwell um then linking in with
the flowing issues on the golf course
um rochford hotel
um around the reservoir
uh the council depot the horse and groom
all those sorts of areas
and trying to understand the the whole
system in that that area
and and how we might be able to
influence it to
sort of control the
uh the flood risk in in that area
so this is very much a sort of
preliminary report on on what we've
managed to find so far
um and thank you very much to uh to
roger and other colleagues from the
environment agency in sort of helping us
understand this and looking at some of
those options
um
i'm not entirely sure where we
we
go in terms of of trying to develop this
as a
a potential project
and perhaps i might uh
if that's all right with you seek some
advice from from david chapman
um as to
what we might do with this next in in
terms of trying to
take forward some further investigation
okay i'll bring david in before we move
to member questions and points
yes so um
we're happy to to look into potential
options here at this location um i've
got the report that's been sent over so
i can share that with the rest of my
colleagues in the team
um we could look at
what potential mitigation options are
available but also funding options
because um obviously funding is going to
be important to delivering anything
uh any mitigation measures at uh
these locations so yeah i'm happy to
take that back to the wider team we can
have a discussion and i'll be i'll
liaise with you with jeff about where we
are on that if that's okay
you know that's that that that's great
because i think what that this piece of
work does
is it just pulls together a number of
contributory factors
that you know
in rainy times or high times and given
the fact that we
have got a lot of river banks coastal
area um
you know it shows the vulnerabilities of
the district um and how all these things
interrelate
but also
you know they need to be split down into
various factors as i said earlier
drainage systems that are in place
management and maintenance of drainage
system and actually what's feeding
flooding issues in the district and this
is a
pretty good strategic report on those
various issues councilman
yeah thank you chairman i think um a lot
of this really does come where we're
looking at where where everything starts
and a lot of it starts from riley hills
uh river roach into there we've we've
looked at what happens with eastwood
brook as it goes through there we have
rayleigh weir
i know dave has been trying to deal with
eastwood brook and what happens there
for a long time
um as yet
we've got no traction at all as far as
that's concerned in in finding solutions
to hold anything back
um the the maintenance uh to the river
roach as in noble's green ditch is now
part of the annual maintenance program
which
has stopped a lot of the flooding and
topping out
which is which is very good but i think
we have to recognize that when these two
come together
they do they're the ones that when
they're in full flow
they flow into the areas that we are
basically talking about
and and we need to look at where it
starts how it starts and what can be
done at that start to fundamentally help
what happens when it ends up
absolutely um comes back to the point if
we understand the geographical aspects
of our district that that that helps
enormously uh council mrs christine
mason
thank you yes sir wilson um
first of all i have to declare i believe
potentially a peculiar interest because
i
hadn't realized this was referring to
the whole rule
that uh because the description is
of where the water flows is actually
inaccurate
um so apologies for that so i'll declare
that now
and perhaps i can add some clarity onto
this because it's
mostly in my world and i know it
extremely well
um
it says here it runs near clements hall
leisure centre and then to hall road
that's not actually accurate
it runs along clements hall leisure
center
at the back of the christmas tree farms
estate it crosses actually thought close
underground as it happens
and it goes along the back it runs
parallel with rectory road
along the back of the properties um in
angle field close which is where my
interest comes in and
um rectory road it is then joined at
windsor gardens by
um a very strong flow that runs the long
parallel long railway line basically
parallel with magnolia road but
obviously you know the hawkwell side of
it
it then goes through a cover into the
farmer's ditches and there it splits
some of that goes towards the
uh beginning of ironwell lane if you
like
um the top end and potentially to haul
road i think across the ditches but the
rest of it goes
joins the eyewear lane a lot lower down
so there's um an area there i will say
that um
where the area is where it joins at
wings or gardens we have had flooding
there in the past and although similar
to the other pipes in the area though
it's not tidal
if the high tide is in the water flow
has nowhere to go
and there has been flooding rectory road
in the past but
in recent years as well
but
it's it is complicated what i would say
is the
area that runs through clements hall and
i believe and behind my house
is actually
designated as a river
and it comes under magnum water and they
have been excellent when we've noticed
anything wrong with it or any blockages
and a lot of debris does because there's
a lot of woods on the clements hall
ground prior to it there's a lot of
trees come down they have been excellent
clearing it and um
maintaining
maintaining it because obviously they're
responsible for some of that so
it's not a potential problem but they
description needs to be
clarified somewhat and i do understand
the difficulty if you don't know the
area where it is it is complex
but if it would help
jeff stacy i'm happy to walk around and
show him some of the areas you can't
pick it up from a map
okay
um
thank you councilman mason certainly uh
jeff has just put his thumb up to that
offer and i agree with you i think um it
just needs to be taken offline so that
there's uh accuracy put on on the point
i mean i think the strategic point of
the paper is really good to understand
what's going on
in the district which is influencing
funding um for a range of issues um but
perhaps you pick that up offline with uh
jeff
um
if i could just come back and say
counselor
ward is correct it starts right high up
in rayleigh and in
in hockley woods and that that's the
where everything starts and perhaps
what we're looking at often is the
result of the problem perhaps we ought
to be looking at
the
beginning of the problem rather than
further downstream it might be helpful
more difficult but probably more
constructive
yeah don't agree and
in some places you deliberately or you
want water deliberately to run slowly so
that it doesn't actually produce a uh a
problem you know it says various
controls um that needs to be put in
place but it's nice to hear your
complimentary comments on anglian water
and their their management that's good
um
mike stefan
thank you chairman um a couple of
questions a couple of points please if i
may uh with regards to the outflow from
the because it all seems to combinate at
the rochester reservoir uh point where
the wholesome room is goes under the
road there uh into uh towards the um
uh um
the title wrote i'm talking about has
account be taken into with the amount of
silting up that there has been in that
particular section
and from title rate that the title
reaches and what effect does that have
second question is with regards to on
the report item 3.18
which is on the very last page 6.7
it refers to flooding as part of in
rockford in sutton road
uh i'm unaware of any form of tidal
flooding coming from
um the ropes and the printerworld brook
there
i'd like some more information on that
because again i think that's possibly
tied in with what i was referring to
earlier as the canal that runs along the
edge of sutton road uh and the gullies
and uh totally listening to what uh
councillor christine mason saying there
was that
are we exploring areas where water can
be slowed down and stored
through high volume
times through things like leaky dams
that type of
situation is that being taken into
account as well
okay um i'm not sure whether um
mean certainly the notes have been made
of the issues uh and i was just about to
bring in david chapman but i see
enthusiastically putting up his hand to
give some sort of view
yeah i mean obviously um every scenario
is different and flooding comes can come
from a number of tributaries but as a
rule of thumb what we do on the capital
programme and the feasibility that i was
talking about earlier that we'll do in
the hockey area is that we look at
trying to capture as much water upstream
and manage it in as natural fashion as
possible whether that be through
reconnection of floodplains leaky dams
creation of additional storage things
like that so it's more natural features
that are environmentally friendly but
also capture the water upstream
without the need for perhaps the more
heavily engineered pipe systems which
in effect quite often all they do is
move the problem from a to p a to b in a
quicker time uh and and then maybe make
a create a problem downstream where
there wasn't one previously
so our methodology will be to take that
forward and that's how we explore all of
our mitigation a couple of program
schemes is that basis is how far
upstream we can capture the water to
manage it better
thank you council award
thank you chairman i just wanted to
refer if i may on this report and have a
look at the page it might be helpful
which will be 6.2
on that report where you've got the
flood risk um i would much appreciate if
um
where we have nobles green or as it is
the roach that runs through railing
and we know that there is flood well we
do clear that area and i do remember
that some time back richard tatt and
bennett
prior to flooding was saying that the
environment agency liked to leave that
area overgrown to reduce the flow the
problem is in reducing the flow it
caused flooding uh to that area and that
was the problem so you know we've got a
bit of a catch 22 so whatever you play
whatever you're gonna think of doing
just i'd like that to be put down as a
risk
on your list that first bullet points um
you know the rally end of the roach
please
thank you council award right okay um
uh comments are being noted council
stepped up you want to come back
you're mute
um thank you very much for your comment
uh but didn't really answer the question
around the silting up of the title
reaches on the roach
and the comment i made about sutton road
flooding
so the build-up of silt on the road is
something that we'll have to refer to
our environment agency colleagues as
that would be main river section there
um
it will be it will be determined by them
as to what the maintenance criteria but
also
i'm sure roger will
um support what i say is that um main
river elements
still have the same riparian land
ownership responsibilities as ordinary
water courses and the smaller staff it
may be more difficult given the size and
the nature of that catchment but um if
it's not on environment agencies
um again i don't miss the missed comment
on the environment agency's behalf but
it may or may not be on their routine
maintenance schedule they will have to
confirm that i won't know but again i
say riparian ownership rights do still
um stand on main rivers as well as
ordinary war courses so that may well be
a riparian ownership issue for clearance
of that
even in the title reaches
uh again i might refer to roger for that
one but again i don't think that affects
riparian ownership i'll say it may be
more difficult and it may be something
that needs to be coordinated with the
environment agency but uh
as far as i'm aware that doesn't have a
bearing on riparian ownership
okay roger do you want to come in
yeah the uh when we went down there with
uh jeff a few months ago
if you look down there a lot of the
outfalls the uh that train in there
are very low lying along the bank so i'm
thinking about the depot
and the horse and groom
and
the situation there is yes the tidal we
we could we could spend money on
clearing out the title sections down
there but all that's going to happen
is it's going to fill up with silt again
so there is no
benefit to actually clearing out the
title section down there salt bridge
which i think is where you're talking
um
with regard to riparian ownership yes
all right parent owners have
responsibilities to clear sections even
along
not potentially the channel but if
there's any outfalls or tidal
lock systems there they need to keep
them in
clear maintenance
that is their responsibility
thank you
back on that
going to the point around the sutton
road uh title reaches there
uh we had a lot of discussions many
years ago around improving the
um
road there new bridge and all the rest
of it many members will remember that
but the interesting point there it was
discovered that the title reaches
were actually considered to be crown
property so are we saying that if the
repair riparian ownership here is crown
property
it's probably crown property but yes i
mean what we're saying is we don't
routinely
clear out crown land which is tidal what
i'm talking about is features like
outfalls and that sort of thing
which are
not owned by the the crown they are
owned by ripone owners
interesting now dilemma there yeah okay
okay thank you uh councilman sue mason
yeah
i'm i might be able to put some clarity
on the riparian ownership um you know i
appreciate that i've looked into it in
quite some depth that's not a pun um
we're
quite right when there's a river that
doesn't um
eliminate the riparian ownership
responsibility but it is reduced to a
certain debt so i think it's about three
feet um so
you go to the middle of the stream and
you go to a certain depth and after that
it becomes
the water authority so it is quite
confusing but it is quite clear you you
can
you know
when you if you know what you've got
behind you which you should do it should
be on your days you should do it but
it's and it is a responsibility to to
prevent uh debris falling into the river
as well
exactly if that helps to clarify it
thank you for that um
right i'm keen to move on um but uh the
report is there before you um and um
i think
we simply note it but uh
welcome it as well at the same time and
all right
we move on then to item seven which is
any other updates um from our partners
uh go to you first david do you have
anything you wish to add
just to follow on from what i spoke
earlier so the hockley um
hockley
critical drainage area
is going to have a feasibilities done
study done later on in the 22-23
financial year so that will give us a
very high level idea of what the flood
risk is
where the sources of that flood risk
come from and also a long list of
potential options mitigation measures
that we could install there that would
be the first part and then if it's if we
deem it to be a viable option we will
then refine those long lists of
potential solutions into a preferred
option or a number of preferred options
if there is um not a one case fits all
solution um we will then look that to
deliver that in future years of the
capital program
um
so at the moment the capital program has
been authorized and i have funding for
22 23 financial year
so that is sitting with me and that has
been guaranteed there is also at the
moment
uh i say at the moment because we know
things may change but there is um a
capital program and budget for that
earmarked for
two years after that as well so i will
have to run through the process of
unlocking that money and like i say
in the next couple of years
we may find that priorities change or or
there are budgetary constraints i can't
answer that but yeah there's definitely
money for next year and for the two
previous years after that as well so
that's updates from essex county council
thank you very much indeed david um and
um i see you've also put in so the chat
area the contact through
the essex county council website which
is basically flood dot essex dot gov dot
uk
can i also just add council woodson um
there is another project that you may
not sort of directly link with uh flood
resilience um but there is an essex
forest initiative
and that is where we are looking to
plant 375 000 trees over five years of
which we are at the end of the second
year
there's a lot of work that we're looking
to do to try and
determine what flood benefits tree
planting has we know it provides lots of
environmental benefits it can provide
shade and cooling the street scene but
also we're we're quite keen to promote
uh their flood risk benefits as well so
if anybody in uh rochard and we work
with your neighboring authorities quite
a lot in castle point and basildon um so
there is a facility for us to look at
providing trees um to be planted if
you've got anywhere that you think may
be suitable and not just yourself but
anybody on this meeting and beyond
suitable locations where you think that
tree planting could take place then
again the email address that i provided
please send any sort of
details that you may have maps
information over to that address and
we'll look at those as potential
planting sites for the essex forestry
initiative program
okay thank you for that and i saw
councillor dave sperring sit up there
and uh make a note as uh
holder for environment i'm sure he's uh
making a note of that as we speak thank
you
right um and we also move on to roger
webster from environment agency do you
have anything to add roger
uh no not really apart from that we've
got a meeting with aurora flood action
group next month to discuss the issues
down there and dave and i should be
attending that
okay and i think that will be a
particular interest accounts for chris
stanley
oh
there we are good all right
no other questions of uh
two partners who are present today
obviously missing uh mark lloyd but we
covered that earlier and
you know we can't forget the good work
that anglia walter are doing as well so
uh been a couple of very positive
comments about their contribution as
well so we do thank you partners all
hands have
gone up jeff if i can take you first
yes it was it was
just to add a
possibly to um dave chapman's comments
that they um
we are also involved with a project
that's going on about eastwood brook
um so i sort of represent rocha district
council on that that sort of project
group
and
it's being led by southend council
um because it's looking primarily at the
the sort of areas that uh run
through their their plot
but obviously it does have influence
both at the rayleigh end um and
the the sort of airport end um for us
um so that is something that we are
actively involved with that project as
well
thank you okay
thank you jeff councilman chris stanley
thank you gentlemen um just like to put
on if we could put on the agenda for the
next time is the flooding at uh swain
park
car park entrance
um off of uh off of roy flame um i have
been in touch with adam and james about
this and also uh councillor dave
spearing knows of this what's going on
and i don't know how how much uh he is
is
happening what what is happening um i'm
waiting to hear from adam or or anyone
um but could i put that on the agenda
please
okay uh council spirit may be coming up
back yeah there's no need in putting
this on the agenda chairman
we have this in hand we're dealing with
it this will just add something that is
already being dealt with and i've told
councillor stanley that i'm on to the
case with this with mr hotton and mr
aldridge so we are dealing with that now
okay um just as it's recorded it might
not be a bad idea just to record it in
the minutes that the solution is being
dealt with so
it'll be recorded in the minutes council
stanley that it's it's something that's
been raised it's being dealt with and
then that gives you an opportunity to
raise it when you sit next in the
minutes if you know you see it's not
going something that's the way to deal
with that one i would suggest is that
all right
thank you thank you very much jim so it
will be recorded one way or another or
it won't come up as a
as an outstanding issue because
hopefully it will be resolved by that
and i also see in the chat that
councillor uh cheryl rose raised the
issues about church road and again that
will be recorded in the minutes of this
meeting
raised outside of the meeting um by
presumably council sparring councillor
um so that that could be recorded in the
minutes and dealt with
following on so
that that means that we're actually
pulling everything together through this
meeting so
here we are
right can't see any other hands um time
is pushing on and we move
um
to
you you haven't got any other updates
that you get jeff
from
partners that are not here nothing else
from you
no nothing further from me thank you
okay thanks right which takes us
um to questions from the public um and i
appreciate that there will be a number
of members of public um patiently
waiting to see how we answer their
questions but as i said this is part of
the problem with the way we're currently
structured if we deal
with
from the public's point of view all 14
questions um we'll be here for another
few more hours
and i'm really looking for a bit of
inspiration as to how
to integrate these questions into the
agenda today
and my suggestion is that we come up
with draft answers to all of these
questions i'm aware that
um
for example
i look at question 13
that has appeared in the minutes
it's appeared in the ongoing updates
it's appearing as a further question
um
so we're not going to be able to add
much value to that today without
quite a lot of questions being asked
behind the scenes so we probably
couldn't give an adequate answer i think
these questions need to be given
due consideration
answers drafted um
circulated actually to uh to this forum
um and certainly recorded in the minutes
as answers but others may have different
ways but to be fair
we wouldn't
do do
justice for these to go through the
other thing i will come back to is my
earlier point some of these are
statements really about planning they're
not specific flooding issues and it does
come back to the the terms of reference
of this meeting are we talking about
specifics or are we actually uh dealing
with planning issues which is a whole
world on its own but let's let's invite
members to come back and see what their
thoughts are cancer slept out
thanks chairman i i was going to pick up
on several of the questions because they
are items
as counselor i can deal with directly
so i'll run through those particular
questions and
perhaps if those particular members of
the public
are listening in
or they're reading the minutes
afterwards would uh kindly contact me
direct through my county councillor
email address
which i'll put on the chat so i can go
into the minutes
uh with regards to question three
um running ditches are running along
um
bowling road um
terms the shopping road uh i need to
know a little bit more information as to
exactly where that is there are it will
be down to the right parent land owners
um but i need a little bit more
information as to where that actually is
uh the certainly the farmers along there
will be very receptive to actually
dealing with the issue there's one
particular landowner there would perhaps
not might not be quite so
so perhaps if they can contact me
correct
question four
um i'll refer to my earlier comment
with regards to the highways um
survey that carried out um and uh we're
waiting on that to be
a report to come back from that so
perhaps uh dave can take that back and
uh
chase that up for me i'd be very very
grateful
uh my question six
um
with saturn with regards to the sutton
road uh again i need a little bit more
in specific information uh to know what
uh outside which particular properties
they're referring
and i will pick that up offline again as
county councillor uh refer the member of
public to
my county email address
um
question number nine
um with regards to the drainage along
south end road rockford and i will tie
that in with question 12.
um
there is um
christian as well yeah going down to
question 12 tie the two together
uh i am discussions with
both south end barrack uh city council
correct myself there and essex county
council and rightful district council a
lot of the problem is
by detritus that's being left on the
railway bridge
and at the moment i can't get anybody to
accept responsibility for actually doing
the maintenance because of the way the
boundary actually runs around the bridge
and over the bridge
nobody's actually accepting
responsibility i do have a meeting
scheduled with the portfolio holder at
county to resolve this issue um
and to actually
uh to afford uh trying to get some sort
of answer on this
with regards to specifically sutton road
uh some time ago and i'm probably going
years
um
um
the officer marcus cotton uh had
allocated i believe it was around 18 000
pounds to buy some new equipment
for cleaning the road along the southern
road because of the narrowest of the
footpaths to my knowledge i don't think
that equipment has been purchased i
would like to see that re-looked at
because keeping the detritus off that
section of road is a big job because of
the traffic coming in and out of
purdue's industrial state
so those those particular questions
chairman again i'll reiterate if members
of the public could contact me direct
uh through my county council website
address
um i'd be more than happy to
pick up on that okay that's really
helpful council stepped up so just as we
clear
questions three
four
six
nine and twelve
um not only um should residents perhaps
take up the offer that council steptoe
is making with his county council hats
on but also i'd like there to be some
liaison through jeff stacy as well who
pulls this meeting together because in
fairness to members of the public they
don't always understand where uh our
powers stop and start and everything
else and we just need to have a
coordinated approach because our part of
our role here or the main part of our
role is to bring the various agencies
together and try and sort of um get
focused on watchful district matters but
uh um i think that's really really
helpful thank you very much indeed for
for that but um jeff if you can sort of
make sure you coordinate
your um responsive with counselor
steptoe
because actually
this part of the agenda is the most
important part to make sure we're
picking up on the new areas um or areas
and deal with president concerns uh
thank you councillor steptoe uh
councillor mcpherson
thank you chairman um mine's really in
relation to um the question too um
across the district we we do get asked
this quite often um one of the things
that perhaps um councillor steptoe could
help with and perhaps tie offices in
together is that there's a coordinated
approach because i believe unless i'm
wrong this is county council organize
the gully suckers
we do the road sweeping so if that can
be
um worked together it can assist each
other
but looking at some early um
sort of intervention i've mentioned
mentioned to you already councillor
wootton um around some of our utility
workers
also developers who have been seen to be
sweeping um
leftover rubbish mud etc down um the
drains
which is probably going to cause far
more problems in issues than leaves will
and i mentioned about could there be
some sort of fine system
um is it possible that within our
conditions there is um a huge note that
if you are caught doing this there is a
hefty fine to cover the costs for um
getting this sorted
councilman you've read my mind it drives
me absolutely mad that um
various people seem to think that just
sweeping all their rubbish down the
drain system
gets it out of their way and then causes
a major problem because the drains then
become blocked um in part it can be
dealt with by regular maintenance but it
it frankly is outrageous that uh
you know
concrete and stuff finds itself lazily
being cleared up because it's easier to
wash it down rather than actually clear
it up properly um you you read my mind
totally but uh thank you for that
before we move on um i don't know if
there's any of our partners who can
advise um can we enforce
some hefty fines if this is called well
can we enforce them do we enforce
because it seems pretty obvious to me
that
we shouldn't allow people to block up a
public system but uh
let's go to one of our partners any
comments
yes if um
if uh there's been deemed action that's
causing an issue in terms of flood risk
or a blockage to a system or anything
that's been unconsented the work that's
been done without our official process
and authorization and yes there is an
enforcement process that can be carried
out there is a criteria for which um
areas we will enforce um but yes there
is a there is a matter of recourse for
us to do that yes
okay um david can you say
for the environment agency in maine
river systems
the same
situation applies we will we could
decide to take enforcement action should
we wish
right okay well we're
if you don't mind me coming back please
chairman um we've got a problem here
that could and would it should be we
will take action
and could you please circulate the
criteria so that we can make that clear
and then when we get reports
if we then pass on those reports to you
and they meet the criteria we would
expect them to be enforced
yep okay thank you uh agree with that
totally it comes back to the point i
made earlier it's nice to see better
maintenance through our
county council colleagues better
maintenance of the system through the
highways network um
it's not perfect there's plenty of
drains still blocked up but it certainly
shouldn't be um
the
county council's job to clear up
people who are willfully sweeping stuff
into
trains and blocking up the
infrastructure so
there we are okay
council award
yeah thank you chairman um mine actually
refers to question 11 and 13. uh we know
13 has already been on the agenda as
plum bro avenue but question 11 does
raise a problem that that i would like
to see addressed
not only uh it needs to be uh throughout
the district we know that there are lots
of subterranean streams and aquifers
running through
the whole of the district um
we just want to know
how have we
are we going to look at mapping these
because unfortunately uh officers in uh
you know in planning if they don't know
something is there
and they're not aware of it then
unfortunately what happens uh in
question 11 and question 13 inevitably
happens now we there is knowledge out
there of where streams were and
obviously have been covered up by
subsequent development
i don't know what we can do to
investigate it and what help you know
either david or roger can do with their
extensive knowledge
thank you council order i'm just a
little concerned that we will move off
focus this is dealing with public
questions um a bit of a boomerang factor
because as uh
portfolio holder for strategic planning
you're in a position to influence some
of this stuff with partners um and uh
certainly you know i'm aware of
um several developments which have
impacted on surrounding areas uh in our
district and uh that causes concerns
about i really don't want to get to the
stage where we're
debating all of these questions i want
to be quite focused uh i believe that
answers should be worked up
where they involve
um jeff and other partners we ought to
look at those drop but there needs to be
dialogue with the residents who have
raised it so that they're given an
appropriate amount of weight in this in
this process um otherwise we'll end up
by just debating the answers ourselves
and actually not really coming up with
comprehensive answers
um
council sparing yeah thank you chairman
just to uh give you an update uh
councillor steptoe mentioned the street
sweepers etc just you know there is a
agreed
procedure that we are now undertaking
to improve
newsweepers what is more appropriate for
this district in preparation for our new
street cleaning contract chairman thank
you thank you
councillor steptoe you have to have your
hand up as well yeah
thank you i think council sparing for
that uh yes i i was aware that uh we'll
be looking at new equipment but uh the
sutton road is particularly a difficult
area because the amount of traffic
running through there from purges up and
over the warner's bridge uh it needs to
be almost done daily uh it is a
horrendous
area just picking up on council awards
point with regards to mapping uh that
sounds to me as if it should be a job
that we should be working with the
parish councils particularly in the
rural areas because they will have the
local knowledge and get the parishes
involved in this particular point i
think would be a big advantage
thank you very much uh david
thank you yeah i don't want to take up
too much time councillor um but it's
just that to let you know that um
ordinary courses that we have
jurisdiction over are very they're not
very often mapped but we do assets as
and when we record issues with them but
also as part of our capital program we
record those assets as well so we're
building up that knowledge
base for ordinary water courses main
rivers coastal areas i think roger will
agree they are quite well mapped and not
well known but also there is a parish
council initiative where
uh parish councils just following on
from council steptoe they can apply to
be part of uh where did your water go
initiative which means that they can go
out and map and record assets for us
return that back to us we will then put
that onto a database uh and that's been
running for a number of years again
quite rightly local knowledge is more
important and it's better than what we
have um so yeah any parish councils that
want to get involved in that initiative
in mapping those assets they can do that
and we can send out a pack to help them
assist them with that
that's really helpful and you know
highlights the partnership approach and
the benefits of this flood forum to get
all these ideas and put them together
and record it in in a minute thank you
very much indeed david um
council ward is that a legacy hand or is
it no no it's just a quick comeback
thank you i was totally unaware of that
um i don't know who wants to coordinate
but maybe jeff can
send out to parishes or whatever to to
get this up thank you jeff you put your
thumb up that's lovely um council
stepped up
yeah the council would just stole my
thunder as i said as a parish councillor
i was unaware of it although we have
been doing it locally um i think it
needs to be resent out both from county
and for districts who actually encourage
parishes to redo it
thank you very much indeed um but in
terms of the questions they're moving
forward they are very very important
that we
give adequacy in terms of thinking about
the answers
some of the questions are do i say more
statements than necessarily expecting an
answer to specific flooding going on in
the district but we will do our best
and um those answers will be drafted in
conjunction with our our partners um but
more than that i don't think we can
actually get any further uh on the
specific questions uh in this meeting um
and and the reason for deferring that is
to
give them the due prominence and
importance that they deserve if people
actually write into us now councillor
steptoe has actually put his email
address in there um and use
counselor.cllr.mike.stepdo
at
essex.gov dot uk so thank you to you
mike for uh for putting that in there
and i think that will be helpful
it is
totally confusing and quite
understandable that members of the
public don't know
what the different authorities have
responsibilities and powers for but
a lot of this stuff does depend on our
county council councillor colleagues um
to pursue um with with officers so thank
you for that um and um
i think that brings us
nearly to the end unless there's any
other business people wish to raise
cancer stepped up
chairman just for for members of the
public that are listening in i will put
all those details onto my facebook page
if they would if they look sure to have
written that down uh it will be on my
facebook page they've only got to look
up steptoe and they'll find all sorts of
things okay and also for the benefit of
uh residents uh we do have five county
councillors uh that sit um across the
district of course councillors here
uh it's a coincidence if they happen to
be a county council because they're
actually wearing their district council
councillor hat uh but i'm looking at uh
councillor mrs laurie shaw
she has a similar
email address
so if people want to go to their
divisions as they call them a county
there are five divisions across the um
across the district covering railing
holbridge uh and um
uh and um
ashington um so uh
and out to the founders on the wakering
so there are five county councillors um
councillor michael hoy councillor june
lumley
um councillor um
james newport uh councillor lauren shaw
and councillor mike steptoe uh and um
you can write to your uh county
councillors in much the same format uh
email wise as councillor mike stucco put
in his uh in his um so it's
cllr
dot
and first name dot
surname at essex.gov dot uk uh i hope
you don't mind me plugging you county
councillors that are on this call um in
the uh in the roles that you you you
take on
um
because that's how we funnel stuff
through our ward members uh councilman
shaw you want to come in yeah just uh
going with what mike said if you look on
my um facebook page um
and they want to anyone wants to contact
me um they can we always put information
out there but obviously you've just said
our emails address got no problem with
that at all
okay chairman lovely thank you captain
chris stanley
um
so sandy you've gone a black screen now
and um you're on mute
i think we've lost you counsellors i
seem to have left the um
disappeared from the call okay um on
that note unless there's any other
business that people wish to raise um i
think it's been a very useful meeting um
and uh just like to thank everyone for
your time today thank our partners thank
our councillors uh thank our officers
within rockford district council the
work that you're doing um
very positive engagement across
the various areas
certainly i would like pressure board to
bear to get a highways representative
flooding is very very important
particularly in our
coastal district with a number of rivers
going through it it may be less
important um some more inland areas but
uh certainly the
um
the the
collective nature of our various
influences over flooding are very very
important we appreciate your attendance
thank you very much indeed today and uh
bang on one o'clock when we were due to
finish this is us finishing so have a
good day for the rest of you thank you
to members of the public as well thank
you
thank you goodbye